you know we talk about the accidents of
history
had al gore
not that well characterized had al gore
won that election i think he won it
anyway
[Music]
oh yeah when questioning election
results was cool that was joe biden
about 15 years ago saying that al gore
won the election
democrat privilege what can i tell you
ladies and gentlemen it is june 29th in
the year 2022 i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report we are live streaming on
rumble youtube and blaze tv do me a
favor and subscribe to our channel and
we're doing something a little different
today
because as you know
or as you hopefully only know in a very
ancillary way there has been this
january 6th amateur theater hour
happening in washington d.c and we have
not covered it here i don't know that
i've mentioned it more than
once or twice in perhaps two or three
sentences in a very passing manner
because i think the whole thing is an
absolute farce much like the 18
impeachments i mean they impeached him
for eating mcdonald's they impeached him
for two scoops of ice cream they
impeached him for ketchup with steak the
whole thing nobody cares about this
thing it's a complete farce the only
people who care about it are the people
that are just trying to support
the swamp the people who are just trying
to make sure trump
can't run again or that you know they
can
continue to pin half the country as a
bunch of white supremacist racists and
the whole rest of that however
however yesterday something so
remarkably idiotic happened in the
hearing uh many of you watching this if
you're if you're on the twitter and you
probably shouldn't be on there you
probably saw the clip already but
something so stupid so ridiculous such a
perfect example of why everyone hates
all of these people and why nobody
trusts the media or our political
establishment happened that i said i
have to show it i have to show it we
have to analyze it we have to talk about
it because these people are horrible so
that is going to be where we start the
show and then from there i thought all
right well that'll give us a nice
springboard to say okay well the dems
seem to be running on january 6. they
really are i mean they're still all
talking about it this is a very scary
thing they're learning new information
18 months later my god they're running
on that and what are the republicans
running on and we are going to compare
and contrast that will be the reuben
report for today january 29th 2022
before i get to any of that though let
me talk to you real quick about real
estate agents i trust people i want you
to move to florida if you're a good sane
person you know buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be 10 times
worse if you're not working with the
right agent generally speaking our homes
are our biggest investment that's a ton
of responsibility and you need an agent
who takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my good buddy glenn beck they
work with only the best agents in every
market they do their homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
their network and here's a big one they
only work with full-time pros no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
their team makes the introduction and
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go to real estate agents itrust.com
today and provide them with some basic
info they'll reach out to you for an
introduction to their preferred agent in
your town and then you move and live
happily ever after okay
so what's happening here in the world
first off before i get to any of that
january 6 stuff one of the things that i
think i've been kind of
hitting on over the last couple weeks is
that we're getting some big wins here
and that's why the hysteria keeps
ramping up that's why the fear keeps
ramping up that's why they're telling
you covet 2 is coming and the rest of it
but the winds are coming at sort of
every level not only they're happening
politically but they're happening
culturally
so you may have heard of this joe rogan
fella he is a comedian and an mma guy he
has a what i'm told is a very popular
podcast on the computer there and he had
gina carano on yesterday and gina carano
who of course you know she was the
actress
uh in the mandalorian who then tweeted
out a meme
and got fired disney fired her she was a
really like almost a perfect example of
cancel culture complete nonsense well
anyway gina carrano was on joe rogan's
show yesterday and rogan now
is even saying that he might support
ron desantis
yeah so all this stuff is happening
while we have a dead man as a president
yeah
you know it's it's just um are you
throwing out anything
any support towards anyone are you gonna
hold off and uh cause i know didn't elon
musk uh come out recently for desantis
yeah i think ron desantis would work as
a good president i think i mean what
he's done for florida has been admirable
look i feel like i'm doing breaking news
right now i wasn't even on purpose
i feel like what he did for florida a
lot of people gave him a lot of grief
but ultimately he was correct he was
correct when it comes to like
deaths he was correct when it comes to
protecting our vulnerable populations he
was correct in terms of distribution of
monoclonal antibodies and he was furious
when the government tried to pull those
they were trying to pull very effective
treatments you know he is not perfect
he's a human being but um what he's done
is stand up for freedoms and people
think that so this this was some weird
gaslighting [ __ ] that went on where
people equated freedom and saying the
word freedom to like right wing bigotry
and hate is so strange
okay so i actually think this is a
pretty important moment because
obviously rogan has the biggest podcast
in the world right and the fact that
he's coming around now and saying man
maybe that guy in florida that ron
desantis who didn't lock everybody down
who went and said hey there are
alternative treatments beyond the
vaccines like monoclonal treatment which
eventually the federal government
stopped florida from being
allowed to administer uh that he's
fought critical race theory that he's
fought all of this gender stuff and then
what he says there really that freedom
then got conflated with somehow being
far right or racist or any of this stuff
it's like i want him to feel even more
uh juiced up for ron desantis obviously
but that's this is good this is really
good marker and what's interesting about
this well it's interesting at a couple
levels first off it's interesting that
gina chrono just kind of threw it out
there you could tell she didn't even
know what she was saying like you know
she's sort of saying hey are you going
to vote for anyone is anyone working for
you knowing that as she's saying it
people are going to pay attention to
that clip they're going to clip it talk
about it etc etc but rogan has millions
and millions especially of young people
who listen to him and if some of them
are on the fence and if some of them
have still been paying attention to
mainstream media and some of them are
worried that ron desantis is this mean
dude and he hates gay people and all of
these things it's like none of it's true
he has relentlessly fought for freedom
and rogan's signaling that he might vote
for him is really
really good why is it also good it's
also good because it might signal to
some other impactful people that you can
put your name out there and say hey i'm
not i'm not just a lib anymore and
you're going to survive who might this
work for perhaps that bill maher guy who
i talk about all the time who often is
praising florida and praising all of the
things about freedom and just shot his
most recent hbo special down here in
miami but then at the same time on his
show had to go out of his way to say
he's not moving to florida well it's
like all right bill
maybe you can come now maybe the rest of
you sort of good liberals non-woke
liberals can all come so this is what
you need you need people to sort of
punch
through the firewall and the firewall is
always oh but republicans are racist and
scary and mean but if you can convince a
guy like joe rogan to do it maybe you
can get a guy like bill maher and then
how about that elon musk guy because
remember this from about two weeks ago
someone asked him online who he's
leaning towards one word de santis yeah
that's right
so something
is
shifting
here and it's good and it's real good so
i hope that rogan will continue to go
down that path and realize
that freedom
and low taxes and making decisions for
yourself are the exact reasons that he
fled california what about a year and a
half ago and we showed that video
yesterday of me on his show from four
years ago basically predicting that he
was going to move to texas because of
low taxes and all of the authoritarian
nonsense of california so your life
sometimes becomes a living breathing
example of the things you eventually
start realizing and talking about he
realized he was getting taxed he said
okay i'm moving to texas now he's
realizing texas is pretty good and
florida's kind of like texas and the guy
running florida is pretty good
all right you guys got the whole thing
but why is it that people are now coming
around to desantis why is it that
they're sort of realizing oh i can say
it and i'm not going to be destroyed
well it's partly because ron hasn't been
destroyed governor desantis hasn't been
destroyed he stands up against the media
but it's also because he's campaigning
on the right things he's picking the
right fights
and the democrats are picking all of the
wrong fights so we have some interesting
info here this is from this is a tweet
from rnc research
and it's a poll that cbs
news did asking about how important
investigating january 6th was and look
what's going on here this is really
incredible from first to last in terms
of what
voters actually care about here's the
order what they care about most to what
they care about last inflation they care
about that economy crime gun policy
immigration abortion ukraine climate
change covid january 6. now do you see
what just happened there the top five of
those things are all things that
conservatives republicans whatever you
want to call them about column at this
point are running on and doing well
these are things that they are doing
well inflation they're fighting biden on
this and try and for the most part
saying okay we can't just keep printing
money that's directly connected to the
number two economy crime obviously the
democrats are destroying all these blue
cities gun policy you're not going to
believe this republicans happen to
believe in the second amendment more
than more than democrats do immigration
well it's biden who's got the border
open and then what is it that the
democrats seem to care about climate
change okay you may care about climate
change or not every 10 years they tell
you something different so be it january
6th nobody cares covid we're over all of
the nonsense so you can see a real split
happening here in terms of what people
actually care about and you got to
remember that
when you go
and vote not only for primaries which
are happening all across the country and
some happened
even yesterday one of the big ones was
that lauren bobert won her congressional
race uh in
colorado
but especially you have to remember it
when you vote for these midterms come
november uh okay so we're about to get
to this january 6th thing it's just so
incredibly
spectacularly stupid you're just gonna
love it uh real quick let me talk to you
guys about policy genius you know let's
face it shopping for life insurance is
no fun at all ain't that the truth all
that hunting down the quotes and keeping
track of who's who it can be a real
hassle but if you've got people if
you've got people who depend on you
children parents or even business
partners it's incredibly important
policy genius is your one stop shop to
find the insurance you need at the right
price and you can head on over to
policygenius.com ruben to get started in
minutes you'll be able to compare
personalized quotes from top companies
to find you the lowest price you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius they
don't add extra fees they don't sell
your info to third parties and they have
thousands of five-star reviews across
google and trustpilot they have an
option that offers coverage in as little
as a week and lets you avoid unnecessary
medical exams since 2014 policy genius
has helped over 30 million people shop
for insurance and has placed over 150
billion billion with a b in coverage
policy genius works for you not the
insurance companies so get started today
head on over to policygenius.com
reuben to get your free life insurance
quotes and see how much you could save
and now back to me okay so here we go
this is a big moment in the history of
the reuben report dave rubin's going to
talk about january 6 the scariest day in
american history
well first off they were covering it on
cnn and
enjoy this little snippet i i think it
has not been good for the former
president i think we've we've made a
case that he was responsible for uh 9
11. he uh or january 6 he should not
have been uh pushing the the election uh
lies
did you catch that did you catch that i
don't know who that woman is it doesn't
even matter middle of the day they're
wasting time on january 6th that this
woman thinks that she's blaming trump
for 9 11. i get it's just a verbal flub
but it's so indicative of the bigger
problem with these people they think
trump is the center of the universe they
think all problems under trump were
because of trump after trump were
because of trump and before trump were
because of trump one more time 9 11.
i think it has not been good for the
former president i think we've we've
made a case that he was responsible for
uh 911 he or s or january 6 he should
not have been uh pushing the the
election uh lies
it's funny i said to you guys i didn't
even know who the woman was conor wisely
pointed out in the middle of this
during the clip her name is allison
stewart she's a republican strategist so
even the republican strategists who they
bring on cnn have in the recesses of
their brain that somehow donald trump is
at fault for 9 11 just absolutely
ridiculous but that is not why we're
covering january 6th today is because of
what i'm about to show you now so during
this complete clown show i mean this
this whole thing is a clown show fake
crying liz cheney pontificating i mean
it's just complete nonsense but
yesterday they had this woman
by the name of cassidy hutchinson
testify she's a former staffer to mark
meadows who of course worked
for the president the president of the
time donald trump and uh by the way when
when they testify in this thing there's
no cross-examination nancy pelosi has
picked all the people on the panel so
this is not a trial
in any sense of the way we would think
of a trial so if you think of a witness
being called and then being
cross-examined by an impartial jury none
of that applies to this thing this is a
complete nancy pelosi theater program
that is what this is but this woman
cassidy hutchinson she worked for mark
meadows we've never heard of this woman
right for 18 months
she had this bombshell that you're about
to hear and she didn't tell anybody but
here she is and she's very emotional
because something really really nuts
happened 18 months ago
the president had
very strong a very angry response to
that
tony described him as being irate
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr angle grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and mr when mr
ronaldo had recounted this story to me
he had motioned towards his clavicles
you know i took uh acting class
in uh about 2007 for about six months uh
little known fact i was in acting class
with melissa roush who played bernadette
on big bang theory one of my good
friends from stand-up comedy she went on
to be quite a successful actress so i
know a little something about acting
that woman is an actress the way she
spoke the way she moved her hand and
also just putting aside what anyone said
she also said she wasn't there this is
something she heard from somebody
somebody told her that this very
ridiculous thing happened and liz cheney
is staring at her the entire time my god
this my whole life depends on what
you're about to say i also sat on this
information for 18 months that you
really need to think about this he's the
president of the united states they're
in it's unclear now it sounds like she
also might have lied at least on a
couple accounts there because at first
she the implication was that they were
in the beast which is the car that they
move him around with which would have
been literally impossible for trump to
have lunged and grabbed the steering
wheel really tried to think about that
trump lunged over and grabbed why do we
have no video of the car just like
zooming out of control veering out of
control driving into a garbage can and
then he tried to grab the agent's
clavicle
i mean this is just
the height of absurdity so anyway this
clip is going viral yesterday and people
are everyone that's sane and there are
some sane people out there everyone's
saying is like this is just such bs like
it reads as bs she reads as a bad
actress this is so rehearsed liz cheney
with her
sad my face is falling off i'm so sad
this is such serious stuff anyway
everyone realizes it's complete nonsense
and then this tweet comes out this is
peter alexander at nbc okay so this is
not a friendly to donald trump and this
is what he said but he is he is a
journalist you know
to some level he says a source close to
the secret service tells me both bobby
engel the lead agent and the
presidential limousine
suv driver are prepared to testify under
oath that neither man was assaulted and
that mr trump never lunged for
the steering wheel i mean it's just so
perfect it was obviously fake now you
have the agent saying that they'll
testify that it was fake but the media
really loved it and by the way i believe
it's on the front page of the new york
times today and i believe it's on the
front page of the washington post today
the bombshell and also just think of the
absurdity 70 how old is trump now 74
something like that
74 trump lunging for the steering wheel
pushing an agent out of the way driving
the car it's oh it's so bananas but they
have broken so many people and trump
derangement syndrome is such an
all-encompassing mental state that a
certain amount of people believe in the
same people who wanted tre trump to step
down because he drank water with two
hands thinks he's pushing agents out of
the way grabbing a steering wheel and
driving to the capitol so he can take
over with the guy wearing the viking
helmet
good god
anyway here's a video of democrats
questioning the results of the 2016
election how can you win with russian
interference though that's something i'm
scared about in 2020 but rightly because
i think he's an illegitimate president
that didn't really win so how do you you
know fight against that in 2020 you are
absolutely right he is an illegitimate
president in my mind would you be my
vice president for
folks look i absolutely agree one thing
that trump
is fearful of uh when it comes to his
being president is that finally we will
see how illegitimate his victory
actually was i have an objection i
object to the 15 votes from the state of
north carolina i object because people
are horrified he's an illegitimate
president stolen emails stolen drone
stolen drone stolen election
welcome to the world of unprecedented
trump
so there you have it those people
actually questioning the results of
election contesting an election uh in
congress calling him illegitimate
believe me there were many many more
videos that we could have shown you of
them doing that but you know when they
do it it's not an insurrection and it's
not a threat to democracy because
they're democrats and they're good guys
and it's you white supremacists racists
who watch shows like this that cause
people to freak out that's the problem
but why are they doing all this why are
they doing all this uh and why are they
having their little show trial as i
often tell you it's to keep the shell
game going they can't have you see where
the ball actually is and pick it up and
go okay i won they can't have you do
that they got to keep the thing moving
all the time so we thought this was
really spectacular remember last july
4th since we're just a couple days away
from the birth the anniversary of the
birth of the united states uh remember
last july 4th when the white house put
out this tweet
planning a cookout this year ketchup on
the news according to the farm bureau
the cost of a fourth of july bbq is down
from last year it's a fact you must herd
hot dog the biden economic plan is
working and that's something we can all
relish and then what they're showing you
there
amongst that full table
is that the cost of a fourth of july
cookout in 2021 is down
16
cents from last year
they
showed that that was not a parody i am
not making that up connor you did not
photoshop that did you know you grabbed
that from the white house official
account it's up there they thought that
was a good idea that's saving 16 cents
when you have a big july 4th party with
the hot dogs and the beans and the whole
thing and as steve martin wisely pointed
out and father of the bride why is it
that they sell you hot dogs in six
package you know a package of six and
the buns in eight it's like are the hot
dog people working with the bun people
to keep everybody off kilter that's
that's actually an interesting economic
issue but they had saving 16 cents and
they were bragging about it well what's
going on this year a year after uh joe
biden's been running the show look at
this as we know inflation has been
impact impacting the cost of nearly
everything and unfortunately that also
includes your fourth of july barbecue
it's going to happen the american farm
bureau federation says it will cost
almost 70 dollars to feed 10 guests at
your independence day cookout it's about
a 10 dollar increase from last year beef
is behind the biggest price jump the
cost is of about 36 percent more than
last year chicken lemonade and potato
salad also have some of this year's
largest price hikes
so just remember
when you saved 17 16
cents not percent when you saved 16
cents last year the average cost of a
cookout this year for july 4th up 17
so we're talking 16 cents and i hope you
spent it well maybe you put it into
bitcoin uh and uh now it's up 17 i am
guessing that the white house is not
going to be tweeting about that but fear
not people
fear not
joe biden is in charge and if he was to
ever break his hip or anything we've got
kamala harris
now
inflation is is really high are you
concerned about a recession the
administration said
um that they weren't that worried about
the about inflation and then
[Music]
that changed i think that
there can be no higher priority
than what we have been clear is our
highest priority which is bringing down
the cost
and the prices as much as we possibly
can and we will stay focused on that
i wish you would find something else to
focus on lady because everything you
focus on turns to [ __ ]
but all right putting aside inflation
for just a moment the other big issue
that they've got right now is the border
and we know you guys are watching this
show so we've covered it plenty i mean
the border is in effect open right now
and thousands of people are pouring
through the border we're giving them
phones we're giving them benefits we
don't know where they are much of this
happened while we were in this pandemic
and they were allowed to come in without
masks while we wouldn't let our own
citizens from foreign countries come in
with masks i mean just all of the the
litany of nonsense right uh it just
never ends and then of course yesterday
there was actually a truly horrific
tragic event where 51 migrants were
coming in in a van that i think caught
fire right uh what happened
did it catch fire i think it caught fire
but 51 migrants were killed
on their way in because the government
has signaled to people
uh health and homeland security director
becerra and biden and kamala they have
signaled to people oh you can come and
then every now and again they go oh
don't really come uh but they basically
said come the van was actually abandoned
in the heat and they they in essence
died of heat stroke it was a semi truck
i mean horrific like actually just like
beyond horrific whether they should come
here or not 51 people are dead like that
and their only reason they're dead is
because they thought they could get in
because our policies are so muddled and
they probably knew people who did get in
so what's happening is as this type of
stuff leaks out even the people
who have backed biden who have backed
all of the progressive policies who have
called trump and the rest of us racist
for wanting a wall or wanting a border
or whatever else even they are now
realizing that they were wrong and here
is guy who is pretty much always wrong
about everything joe scarborough
it's one thing i don't understand
it it's kind of like
when i talk about homelessness there's
nothing progressive
about
having people
sleeping in 10 degree weather sleeping
on greats that's not progressive
there's also nothing progressive about
encouraging migrants to risk their lives
going across the desert
uh to come into the united states
illegally it's just extraordinary though
because it is progressive to do that it
is progressive to say that borders are
not good and that everyone can be here
and we are here for everybody and open
for everybody and by the way we're also
the most evil racist country in the
world i don't know why you want to come
here but okay you can still come here
and yes homelessness is progressive
because everywhere progressive politics
are put into practice
that is where homelessness thrives
that's where you get tent cities that's
where you get the drugs and the rest of
it do i have to go through seattle and
portland and uh san francisco and los
angeles and denver and everywhere else
that's where it's happening so you can
say it's not progressive and i get that
you guys you know you pretend that we
all are there's something wrong with all
of us but i get it you guys have like a
bug in your brain and that bug is like
you cannot make the connection between
all the stupid things that you say and
do and votes that you make and then what
that actually does to people on the
ground so you're saying it's not
progressive but actually it's the most
progressive thing having people come to
a country uh that there is not enough uh
resources for them or have uh high tax
positions so that more and more
homelessness comes into a city these are
the progressive policies of today it's
just that you sound like a nice guy as
you're ruining everybody's lives we've
got more from the televised mental
institution known as msnbc here's willie
geist realizing finally that biden and
the democrats have a problem there was a
special election just a couple of weeks
ago down along a border a district a
place where a republican hadn't won in a
very long time and a republican took
that took that district so there
we've talked about this with progressive
pollsters by the way who say this idea
that
latino voters in america are all in and
they're they have this open mind and
they'll go with democrats wherever they
go on immigration is just wrong it's
just it's just folly and it's not true
and it's patronizing in many ways to
make those assumptions so yeah democrats
will have to reassess because some of
them may not want to use the word crisis
but it's exactly what it is down along
the border when you have customs and
border patrol having
seven thousand eight thousand encounters
and apprehensions a day on the border
that is a crisis
so there's a couple interesting things
there one of them is that uh the
republican that he's referring to that
he refuses to say her name you know her
name it's myra flores she won in texas
34th district as a republican it had
been democrat controlled for 100 years
you may remember that elon musk
supported her he said it was the first
time he had ever voted for a republican
it is a border city it is a place where
people are getting the first hand the
first order effects of this crazy
immigration policy when when the biden
administration refuses to protect our
border which is one of the few things
that the federal government is actually
supposed to do but they won't say her
name and and that's not nothing because
think about the way the entire
mainstream media pushes aoc down our
throat pushes ilhan omar down our throat
and the rest of the squad we know their
names because they're good young pretty
or something progressive politicians so
we should all know them but here you
have a young woman who is a mother who
is latina
who is an extraordinary human being uh
she wins in in texas right
getting rid of 100 years of democrat
rule and we're not even going to say her
name we're not even going to say her
name well guess what she went to d.c
myra flores i'll say her name she went
to dc she brought her kids she was
getting sworn in and look at the way
nancy pelosi treated her young daughter
this is absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible
um
[Music]
now nancy pelosi is just a vile
disgusting alcoholic
swamp creature of the worst order
you don't elbow a kid like that i have
never elbowed a kid like that in my
entire life you don't do that why wasn't
that all over the news imagine if a
republican did that imagine if ted cruz
had just elbowed uh some democrats kid
you think you'd hear about that rand
paul
elbow to kid but nancy pelosi instead of
saying excuse me young lady we're trying
to get the picture here and oh why don't
you move forward this way uh joe biden
would have sniffed her hair so i guess
is elbow which would be worse would you
say elbowing or sniffing hair sniffing
hair seems worse to me than just a
casual elbow but i think that we could
all argue uh either way but the point is
she just elbows this kid wha i mean
these people are
absolutely horrible and once again this
is just democrat privilege you're
allowed to elbow
a young latina girl to get out of the
way in the picture and by the way the
girl took it she took it on the chin so
to speak i mean she took it with total
class she didn't do anything that she
shouldn't have done i mean but nancy
posey is a vile wench and a disgusting
human being i just want to be clear
about my feelings on
nancy pelosi but the other issue
of course that the democrats keep
running on is all of this nonsense
related to gender and wokeness and that
just because you were born a boy doesn't
mean you're actually a boy and
everything else uh here is rachel levine
who is the guy in charge of what is he
is the deputy health secretary uh and uh
very excited to talk about kids chopping
off their genitals
gender affirming care is life-saving
medically necessary
age appropriate and a critical tool for
health care providers
as a pediatrician when it comes to
making sure kids are healthy and happy
i know how important care that affirmed
someone's true identity can be
okay first off there's no science behind
what he just said right there that
person also lived their life their
entire life as a man until a couple
years ago right about five years ago
that was a dude with a wife and kids and
the whole thing now dresses up like a
woman and and we are supposed to pretend
that there's any science between gender
affirming care
also think about the way they use the
words backwards gender affirming care if
you were affirming someone's gender
wouldn't you be saying oh you are a
biological girl we will do everything we
can to affirm your gender you may have
some feelings within you
that are not connected to your
biological gender but we are going to
either disaffirm that or when you become
an adult then you can live the way you
wish to live okay that would be okay but
they are they're calling gender
affirming care it's the reverse of
gender affirming care they it's gender
confusion care is actually what they are
doing if you are listening to rachel
levine that guy who is i mean that is a
guy he lived his whole life as a guy
that is it i could lose i guess we were
off youtube probably today we had a good
run it was a hell of a run you know but
if they take me off you know what i'll
do you know what i'll do
i'll come out as trans and then they
will have taken off a woman off youtube
that's what we're gonna do it's just you
guys get it it's all so ridiculous and
everyone gets it everyone can see
through it it is pure nonsense it is not
affirming to chop off a young child's
genitals it's not
but
because we try here at the show i said i
said guys please
find me a democrat there must be a sane
democrat there has to be one sane
democrat and we did find one although
she wasn't treated very well by the
democrats you know this 50th anniversary
of title ix really highlights the
incredible opportunities and progress
that have been made over the last 50
years and so when you see actions like
those taken by the biden administration
today and a lot of the the changes that
we've seen that are essentially pointing
to the erasure of women both through
actions like hey we're not going to call
use the word mother or father in
legislative language we're not going to
say a uh
mother we're going to call someone a
birthing person
and then you see the biden
administration really rejecting the
objective reality that there are
biological differences between a man and
a woman a male and a female and so i
felt it was so important to stand with
these brave athletes and their families
today who came out really to say hey yes
there are very clear differences and
there are very negative consequences to
the decisions that are being made by
this administration and others that are
hurting girls and women
yeah
truth i made it refreshing when you hear
a little bit of truth uh as you know of
course tulsi gabbard was a congresswoman
i'm not a biologist but i know she's a
chick
from hawaii she ran for president the
dnc basically tried to destroy her
hillary clinton said that she was a
russian asset and then joe biden chose
kamala harris who was polling at zero
within her own party instead of possibly
looking at
tulsi gabbard and in which case imagine
just how different this all could be if
they would have done something honest
instead of something woke uh but of
course it's not just
rachel levine and all of these
ridiculous people it's what's happening
culturally so this is really incredible
so you guys know chris ruffo from the
manhattan institute who i've had on the
show many times i think he's on on
friday right chris ruffo's going to be
on the panel on friday he has done an
absolutely incredible job of exposing
what's going on over at disney and
what's going on at many of these woke
corporations he's the one that leaked
that original internal video uh from the
diversity equity and inclusion group at
disney where they were talking about uh
their secret gay agenda or as they
called it their not so secret gay agenda
and all of the ways that they were
trying to confuse kids about gender well
he found
video from a new disney show called
baymax and watch what they're subtly
doing here yeah men can have periods
here we go
[Music]
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
oh um
well
these are the tampons i usually use
thank you i prefer pads they're more
comfortable for me thank you i always
get the ones with wings thank you get
unscented and bleach free if you can
thank you yo my daughter loves these i
think these might be easier if it's our
first period these are really
environmentally friendly
what is going on here
what is going on here so i don't know is
baymax is he a robot or an alien or is
he an alien robot is he a boy or a girl
i have no idea but yes there was a boy
character a male character wearing a
trans shirt of course
and he says what kind of tampons he uses
what parent is letting their kids watch
this [ __ ] this absolute [ __ ] they are
coming for your children's brains is
that not enough to get you to wake up to
woke mess i think so uh but okay so
these are all the uh the crazy issues
that they're running on they want boys
to be girls they want you to think that
donald trump is commandeering a car to
drive to the capitol to god knows what
he was going to do there and a whole
bunch more but what else what else do
they have
well they've got covered to
the sequel
two years ago cobra 19
didn't need any reminders about how
critical investments health care systems
were
and how sick and health security is
both to fight the pandemic
and to prepare for the next one because
it will not be the last pandemic we
under we have to deal with
that's why the united states together
with g7 partners in the world bank
are investing in a new industrial scale
vaccine manufacturing facility in
senegal and to prepare for the next one
because it will not be the last pandemic
we under we we have to do
all right as always he cannot say one
complete sentence without slurring
without reading properly etcetera
etcetera but yes they're bringing back
ovid do not think that they won't do it
do not think they won't inject it with a
little monkey pox and spin it around in
a centrifuge and sneeze it all over you
to scare the hell out of you because so
many of the markers are showing that
they are going to get decimated in the
midterms and then what will they do what
will they do once kobit comes back the
same people who are out on the streets
right now saying my body my choice leave
me alone my body individual rights
personal autonomy etc etc they will be
demanding that you be injected with
their experimental concoction of lunacy
that's what they'll be doing and it will
be cheered on by all the mainstream
media we put this video together i think
connor this might be your finest work
it's just so perfect here's whoopi
goldberg versus whoopi goldberg
i don't want to force anybody i don't
want anybody coming in my house telling
me how to raise my daughter and what she
needs because they don't know well you
know it's my rights and but okay
but i don't
care
i will tell you this is my body
and nobody you you know you got people
telling me i gotta wear a mask or don't
wear a mask or do this everybody wants
to tell me what to do but you won't let
me make my decision about my body you
are not
the person to make that decision my
doctor and my self and my child that's
who makes the decision we need to do we
need to do this and it's not gonna it's
not gonna allow us to be without masks
until we all do it because quite frankly
i'm not going outside until i know
everybody outside has had the shot when
you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you how dare you tell us
what to do we'll put a damn mask on
because you know i'm sick of talking
about your rights
let's talk about my rights my rights are
as
important to me as yours are to you i
don't want to get sick put a bloody mask
on man girl please stop talking
[Laughter]
girl please stop talking connor you're
getting guacamole today uh that's just a
perfect example of what these people do
right two years of you have to behave
how we want you to behave you have to
inject yourself with certain things you
have to put masks on your face and now
for the last two weeks leave me alone
the government has no right to do
anything i don't have to listen to
anybody else i am in charge of my own
health care blah blah blah blah that's
not evolving politically that's
devolving politically in your thoughts
so let's bring this whole thing full
circle because uh there's this aoc girl
and unlike myra flores from texas who's
got some of the right ideas and they
refused to say her name on television
this girl gets plastered all over tv she
was on colbert last night but before we
show you that
here she is screaming about what she's
going to do
related to abortions
i'll start with the babies of the
babiest of the baby steps open abortion
clinics on federal lands
do you realize how twisted it is how she
repeatedly said the baby of the baby of
the baby steps while she's talking about
abortion like these people are genuinely
evil i just don't know how to say it in
any other way uh what she's calling for
there is abortion clinics on federal
land now the supreme court just has
decided through the reversal of roe that
the federal government has nothing to do
with abortion so i'm fairly certain the
federal government funding abortion
meaning using federal funds for
something that the supreme court has
just decided has nothing to do with the
federal government would be illegal i
know they don't care about the
constitution they don't care about the
supreme court unless it does what they
want and all of that but these people
are just absolute maniacs but what
happens when you're a progressive maniac
you get on all of the tv shows and you
get to be uh
basically massaged by uh stephen colbert
who is one of the least funny people in
the history of the world for three
segments she did three segments last
night not just like a two minute thing
she did three full segments oh full
chock full of comedy here's just a tiny
bit
uh you know there's some speculation as
to whether president biden is gonna run
in 2024 there's some there's some
reports he's a little frustrated that
people keep asking because he keeps on
saying yes and people go are you sure
are you sure
um you know uh i know somebody who's
gonna turn 35
about a month before the election in
2024
uh they represent new york's 14th uh is
is that job appealing to you at all um i
think that theoretically uh listen i
think that we need to focus on keeping a
democracy
for anybody to be president
in the next couple of years and that's
my central focus is helping the people
of this country so it's possible so it's
possible i don't know about it
i'm just here to get you in trouble
exactly
first off putting aside her fake
laughter and just the way the whole
machine massages her and you can see
they're pushing biting out joe you fool
and i get your muddled and confused and
you didn't know what you were getting
into in the first place and there's a
special place in hell for dr jill biden
because of what she's done to you but
they're pushing you out old man and you
can see how the machine's doing it
colbert i mean when they do these things
this is all planned he works for cbs
it's a giant corporation that basically
is telling him what to say through a
series of writers and executive
producers and all of those things and
we're lee okay let's start talking to
aoc remember just remember a month ago
nobody was talking about if there's
anything wrong with biden if he's too
mentally compromised or whatever else it
might be now everyone's kind of talking
about it and guess what that's going to
keep going as his approval ratings keep
going down so the machine is pushing you
out you'll bastard and it's going to now
prop up this crazed communist
oh i i wanted to do it
i was going to do c word i was going to
do c word i didn't do it i didn't do it
my my better angels
thank you thank you for that
um i don't like her so anyway the point
of all of this today
is to bring this thing full circle is
that we started with the with the joe
rogan stuff joe rogan's saying that he
will likely vote for desantis elon musk
saying he will likely run a vote for
desantis that is the red pilling of
america there is a reality out there and
if you pay to pay attention to
mainstream it ain't easy to see but in
the reality of america in terms of what
people care about inflation some of the
other stuff that we talked about there
is a side that's doing it better and
then there's another side that is
massage by the media that wants you
afraid of kovid that wants you to think
that donald trump commandeered a car and
that wants to turn your sons into
daughters so if you'd like to vote for
them good luck with all of that
all right we got a couple comments from
the locals community anya says affirming
doesn't seem to be a strategy for any
other mental illness why is that
you know that's really interesting that
actually is really interesting like if
you think that you're a donkey or if you
think that you're a
a airplane would they affirm that no
that is not to say that and i'm just
tired of saying these sorts of things
that you shouldn't have sympathy for
people that are trans that have gender
dysphoria but we know that most people
grow out of it and the idea that we're
doing this to kids is completely insane
and that you're that you would take
advice from rachel levine who lived his
whole life as a man until a couple years
ago and is now saying that your young
kids should have their breasts chopped
off or their genitals chopped off i mean
it's it's it's genuinely psychotic so
there is no other way to talk about it
uh than to address it as such uh anne
parker says at the primaries in oakland
oklahoma it appeared republicans came
out three to one to democrats well look
oklahoma obviously is a red state and i
know the governor just won his uh in
within the party last night uh the
republican nomination so that's great i
met him last week actually really good
guy and i think we're gonna we're gonna
try to get him on the show he's got some
interesting stuff there that he's
fighting the federal government on right
now uh related to native american land
and what the feds are trying to force
them to do in oklahoma but yes the
signals for the red wave are strong
but
please people don't get overconfident
that is literally the worst thing that
you can do right now because there is a
lot of time there is a lot of time a
summer of violence
coveted two whatever it is there's just
a lot of time so don't get over
confident keep your eye on the ball and
note
as i tried to do in this show that other
people are waking up too jordan says
can't wait to see you at the miami
improv that's right miami improv july
14th and christina pusha
she is ron desantis press secretary
she's absolutely a
fire thrower when it comes to destroying
the mainstream media she's going to join
me on stage i may get a couple other
local miami uh twitter people and
quasi celeb
politics type people who will join me
you can get tickets at daverubin.com
events as always if you want to chat
live during the show go to
reubenreport.locals.com we've got a cold
close for you in a moment part one of my
interview with south dakota governor
christie gnome is up right now the full
thing is already up ad free out locals
my panel on friday is chris ruffo who i
mentioned earlier uh the brilliant
spencer clavin from the daily wire and
josh hammer who is the op ed the head of
the op ed section at newsweek which
is like
completely bananas they have an actual
sane person running the op-ed page of
newsweek who knew anything's possible
anyway i've enjoyed the show today i
hope you did too here's kamala harris
calling joe
here's kamala harris calling joe rogan
joe rogan here's kamal harris calling
joe biden a racist
um i do not believe you are a racist
and i agree with you
when you commit yourself to the
importance of finding common ground
but i also believe and it's personal and
it was actually very it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and
you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me
so i will tell you that on this subject
it cannot be an intellectual debate
among democrats we have to take it
seriously we have to act swiftly as
attorney general of california i was
very proud to put in place a requirement
that all my special agents would wear
body cameras and keep those cameras on